elle déverse presque en continu un flot
de véhicules tout droit descendu des
rampes de plateau caillou la rue poivre
de saint paul en a perdu son cachet le
souvenir de pierre poivre ses fastes il
lui aussi
est-ce que vous avez des pierres quoi
moi quand j'ai appris le tri j'applique
uruguay il ya du courrier qui arrive en
confirme quoi bon alors je sais pas très
bien ce soir
la personne qui a fait ça pôle tennis
par ou bien c'est la grosse boîte
pourquoi la pirate japon cette fois vous
chers points vers quelqu'un
des épices c'est un cultivateur et qui
dessus des preuves et pis qu'a menées le
l'île maurice et la réunion doivent à ce
botaniste émérite l'introduction de
nombreux arbres fruitiers des hippies
néant 10 719 pierre poivre se destine à
la vocation religieuse aventureux il
court le monde pour prêcher la bonne
parole sur le navire qui le ramène de
chine
il perd son bras droit lors d'une
attaque débarqué à batavia il cherche
les moyens de rafler au hollandais le
monopole des épices en 1753 il débarque
à l'île de france avec quelques pieds de
muscadiers et de girofliers volet il les
a climat avec succès au jardin de
pamplemousses
la france a désormais le secret de la
poule aux oeufs d'or
ces colonies de l'océan indien ne vont
plus seulement lui coûter de l'argent
mais aussi lui en rapporter trois ans
plus tard il est rentré en france et
mène une vie studieuse au sein de
l'académie des sciences de lyon il donne
des conférences et participe au dîner
monde à la veille de son mariage en 1767
la france lui propose le poste de sa vie
intendant d ile-de-france et de bourbon
et le voilà reparti pour cinq ans de
travail à développer l'économie des îles
des mascareignes
malheureusement fâché avec le gouverneur
général dumas il est renvoyé en france
pierre poivre meurt à hyères en janvier